some guy that no one knows can can throw
out this ridiculous hot take and it
drives people crazy
like who cares what some guy
i don't know who the guy is and he says
tyree kill's the greatest deep threat of
all time and people are losing their
minds about it again that's what happens
in late may in the nfl it does let's you
know i mean of course it's it's about
who you're associated with too that uh
gets some of that traffic and and
conversation going you know i think
that's part of it too
listen
you know i'm not going to sit here and
say he's the greatest of all time but
he's up there i i don't give a damn i i
don't know who said it either i didn't
even look i don't know i saw it trending
on twitter yesterday too i didn't really
know we were going to talk about it on
the show but either way
like it's i'm cool with talking about it
it's a good conversation and i will say
yes i think tyree kill is up there in
the all-time
conversation for best deep threats he's
he's go ahead what do you want to say
what what well i i just i'm just i'm
very curious about this and i'm i'm
committed to full transparency
to the to the viewers i'm looking at the
the text message it came from pete last
night at 6 48 p.m eastern segment 5
best deep threats in nfl history
um and i see
sims
phil
it's not danielle i'm on there it's not
it's not charlotte yeah so don't act
like you're surprised by it no well i
mean i i'm not surprised by it i knew we
were going to talk about it like i
didn't like sit here and do research and
go let me go through you know i'm a
historian already so i already know this
we also had a br a moment of breaking
down the vikings on that that thing too
and i wasted a lot of time studying that
roster for nothing last night too so you
know sometimes crap doesn't go the way
it's supposed to blame it on t-bone
that's right so you thrown out of the
balloon basket and the vikings breakdown
got thrown out in favor of our question
about that yes right now by the time we
get around to that next week nobody
cares anymore we gotta strike while they
aren't yeah no i 100 you're right and
melissa i like this conversation but i
i'm i'm whoever the guy was that started
this all right
i'm not gonna disagree with him a whole
lot i'm not i don't know call me stupid
call whatever you want but we're talking
about guy that is arguably the fastest
receiver in the history of football he's
in that conversation for one of the
fastest people we've ever seen in the
game and he is the number one deep
threat in an era where it's all about
throwing the football and his
quarterback is famous because of wait
for it yes the bomb the deep throw
everything like that and might have
the most standalone
big deep throw
we saw
in the last decade with that catch in
the super bowl and two or three jet wasp
and that post corner and all that i can
get behind it i'm not going to say he's
better than randy moss all right that's
where that's numero uno on deep ball but
if somebody else went i think tyreek
hill is number two i wouldn't go that's
insane you're an idiot i'd go up i'd get
it he's pretty damn good not many people
could cover him man-to-man
i uh
uh look
i i i don't disagree that tyree kill is
up there but the idea that he's the best
ever i think people reacted the way they
did because the the perception is young
guy
who i know just ignores what randy moss
did what kitty moss did was incredible
the vikings tweeted yesterday
every randy moss 40-plus yard touchdown
of his career it's a 10-minute highlight
reel included his time with the vikings
and then the patriots the raiders the
patriots the 49ers had to play on there
so
it when you see it one after another you
got to go take a nap no it wears you out
it's incredible what the guy did it's
incredible and yeah let's talk about
this guy because we talked about tyreek
first off
randy moss is also
one of the fastest people to ever play
in the history of the nfl i know people
might not realize that because each one
of his strides is like seven yards long
so it doesn't look like he's moving fast
but i could tell you from seeing them in
person or anything that ever anybody who
ever played against them or anything in
randy moss's prime it was
it's in the class of the daryl greens
and the dion sanders and the tyree kills
and all those type of things except he's
a praying mantis that's six four and a
half so that's a different like specimen
all together so you're right i'm never
gonna not say randy moss isn't the the
best deep threat of all time but i don't
think tyree kill is far off again
i've seen bill belichick in new england
play defenses against tyree kill that
i've never seen anybody play against
anybody ever and have never seen new
england do like i've talked about with
you before in that afc championship game
so
that i think when you take that and the
context clues of how people approach him
and covering him he gets
that type of respect at least to be
the great deep ball threat of our era
for sure which i do think throws him in
that conversation for all time too
okay so let's take tyree kill off the
table and focus on today
yeah
other than tyrique the best deep threat
in the nfl today is who oh
i guess
i mean i come to a few names am i
allowed to do that
go ahead yes i mean dk metcalf dk
metcalf is certainly one that pops in my
brain right away
terry mclaurin is another one that pops
in my brain right away
and then
i'm also
dj moore of the carolina panthers
i i think for like for those three
those are the ones that jump out to me
right now and there's some other good
ones don't get me wrong i know that but
i i look at that i don't know mike
what's what what's the first few names
that come to your brain
well you know what came to my brain
isn't the guy who
is
the
best deep threat other than tyree kill
it's the guy who i believe could be and
that's your guy chase claypool oh no
doubt
let him uh if they would let him
flourish he could be 4-4
was his official combine speed in the
40. randy moss ran an unofficial 425 at
the marshall pro day in 1998 who knows
what it would have been
officially scouting combine 40-yard dash
he didn't run it his unofficial was
4-2-5 i mean claypool reminds me of moss
i just was great we both were frustrated
last year they didn't use him yeah
the way that they could have or should
have used him and it'll be interesting
to see if they they start unleashing the
ball down the field to him this year
because he could draw those defenses he
could make those catches and he could he
could i'm not going to say he could be
almost as good as randy moss but he
could be the closest thing that today's
game has to one he's that type of
specimen i mean yeah not maybe not quite
that speed like you're saying randy but
it's it's not far off but yeah he's that
kind of like
i don't care who you are you can't cover
me i'm just too great of an athlete type
of guy he has that superstar potential
to be
that dk metcalf or whoever like you're
talking about you're right i would think
we see that next phase in their offense
this year where he becomes a real deep
threat because we are expecting right we
talked about them yesterday
running the ball power element ooh
safety's come up you got to stop naji
harris zoom there goes chase claypool
big ben throwing a deep ball to him so i
hear you i think that's a great great
like out of the
main wide receivers conversation a guy
to look out for um
i you know of course julio jones in his
prime was that type of guy
you know also right now
you know
mike evans even though it wasn't as much
last year he's been a great deep threat
throughout his career just go look at
his average yards per reception and i'll
even throw like a guy like aj brown in
there aj brown i mean man how many times
during the year do we look at it and go
whoa there he goes her 70-yard touchdown
there he goes through a 60-yard
touchdown and you can't always look at
average yards per catch with some of
these guys too because what happens they
beat people deep everybody plays deep
coverages on them so now a team has to
throw them some wide receiver screens
and some short passes and things like
that to draw people up and it hurts
their average yards per catch which
might make them look like they're not as
good as a deep threat and that's not
necessarily the case either
randy moss though and and let me put
this button on it before we take a break
yeah he's the only guy i remember where
whatever the vikings offense was
whatever the plays were that were drawn
up there was this loose sense of any
time it looked like he's in single
coverage
forget about the play that was called
randy goes deep if it looks like they
have anything other than two guys on him
he goes that's it oh and if they would
push off if they would stay back and
give him a huge cushion
then the the the improvisation was he
would just pull up shortly
right exactly you're right he'd go he'd
be 20 yards down the field be like well
i can't get past the safety he's 40
yards deep let me just sit here and
dante will throw it to me
you're you're exactly right and mike
i'll button it up with this when i got
to the bucks in 2003 after they won the
super bowl that defense right one of the
greatest of all time
there was two names that i always heard
from those guys just you know in the war
stories of oh wow this guy's a freak do
you remember this you remember that
right talking with their coaches those
kind of stories barry sanders won right
i mean they had to play him and deal
with that so he was a legend and randy
moss he was the other guy i can still
remember like my first few weeks there
john lynch and rondae barber just being
like you know they were making jokes
about it about how they had to worry
about getting deep with him and those
type of things so you know that says a
lot too moss is one of the greatest
specimens to ever play the sport
after one year of randy moss the packers
drafted three defensive backs and barry
sanders retired that's all you need to
know that's right you need to know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports